[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time once again to look at the map
updates in fortnight season 9 every few
weeks we meet up and go through all the
changes that have happened if you want
to jump to a specific week the time code
will be in the description below so if
you can't remember from week 5 onwards
just jump straight to it anyway you
ready I'm ready let's do this
oh and by the way use code atom arrow in
the font night shop if you'd be so kind
week 1 after leaving the bunker with
hobo T foo new areas of the map were
ready for our attention tilted towers of
retail row were destroyed in the
previous season's volcano attack
and now replaced by neon filled
futuristic builds the Megamall and neo
tilted oh look
blimps remember the rune spots back in
2018 well at each of these regions a
drone like air platform appeared
energized by the power of Kevin the cube
oh and the power coming in to neo tilted
there's a power line running all the way
from loot Lake and the vault we unlocked
last season I wonder what will happen
when the power runs out maybe we'll find
out in season 11 oh and a new ways to
get around in season 9 the air streams
kind of like bladeless fans the volcano
which caused this Cataclysm is now a
crater a shadow of its former self now a
power plant once again used to energize
the island new technology there seems to
be a theme running through the season as
there's another power source the wind
turbines which sprang up on the high
areas of the map so we have wind
geothermal and alien or supernatural
powers somewhere here too climate change
is real ladies and gentlemen up in junk
Junction the wreckage of the volcano and
everything it destroyed was slowly
gathering here such as the og clock
tower or the memories rip the dream
small changes included a wooden fish in
the swamplands area at the north of the
map truckasaurus looks to be a lot
happier - and houses southwest of
Megamall had an upgrade
oh and here's where we find that giant
fish which somehow ended up here it
still works by the way yes indeed and
the greatest addition to the new season
is John Wick's house I want van buy too
much but yeah no eaves anyway John
Wick's house is here and so too is the
Continental the hotel in which he stays
went on assassination missions and
keeping in with the film the basement in
his house has hidden loot bloody genius
another tiny change which could grow
into something is the hut above the farm
it was destroyed by Kevin all those
seasons back but now has begun the
repair process let's see what happens
next
and one last update the giant chair
which became a toboggan is now an
intergalactic ship potentially
foreshadowing space next season we shall
see
[Music]
week two has arrived let's look at all
the map changes the bow there's none
there's none this none at all none
nothing happens in week two see you next
week
things are now beginning to heat up in
week 3 after polar peak was hit by the
volcano late last season we knew
something must be going on here well
this week the ice began to melt the
impact has sunk in and could be ad or
something behind there is going to be
shown
we shall not know more until next week
but it's bloody exciting isn't it all
the same over in the West a new house is
being built a new construction using the
foundations of the original house in
this location an architect has decided
to do his own thing and damn Maps ugly
as hell but you do it fella Ubu things
get even freakier inside as a shrine to
a pizza Pete can be found that is weird
what on earth is happening here let's
check back in future weeks but now comes
the update we really need it the stone
family love story continues last season
Rock the Dwayne Johnson and his fiancee
Sharon Stone run into each others arms
and when I say ran I mean slowly
meandered over 9 weeks but they made it
all the same now in season 9 their love
has been consummated and they have a son
little stone Stan the family have a plot
of land to enjoy just above lonely Lodge
I love this family
[Music]
wig for what's new this time around
straight back to that stone family and
their new plot of land little stone stan
has vanished
no okay he's only going for a walk don't
panic
he's venturing out into the new worlds
but please PLEASE epic games don't
murder him he means more to me than my
own family at this point anyway if we
look around this area it's likely that
stone Stan will find a pet because
slightly north is a dog on a tree don't
worry he doesn't have a stone taja yeah
I checked and I know I shouldn't have
the stone family may be the greatest
story ever told but the biggest news of
the week is this big bugger down at
polar peak a freaking eyeball is in the
mountainside basically the melting area
is giving him a way to get out of that
block of ice and get this his ID follows
you it's completely aware of its
surroundings it has to break free at
some point I'll call it now it will
trample straight up the island all the
way to loot Lake by the way I legit did
this for about three houses I officially
have no life also this week the Viking
village takeover of snobby shores is
finally complete they fought wealth but
this area is effectively Viking village
from now on
[Music]
holy Sh week five has given us a massive
update to that monster in polar peak
because he's escaped or it's escaped or
she's escaped I'm sorry I'm not sexist
and by the looks of those footsteps it's
Mike Wazowski the monster has not gone
to loot Lake as I expected it's gotten
first whim beelining straight over the
snow leaving footprints behind and into
the ocean now who's gonna stand looking
for it in the sea for hours oh the
noticeable updates this week see at the
stone boy and the dog get a little
closer together but come on the hurry up
the suspense is killing me
the dogs sake oh and hood watch it's got
a second layer now from from destruction
to restoration and now improvement what
is going to happen next two random
guesses are needed I say it's a clock
tower Oh
out of nowhere someone indeed did spot
the monster in the ocean it looks like
he's carrying polar Peaks castle on his
back kind of like Shadow of the Colossus
let's see where he goes next out of
nowhere the modern house in pleasant
park has been destroyed holy [ __ ]
Batman who would do such a thing
it must be that polar peak monster going
back over to snobby shores we can now
see that the house on the right has
literally been stepped on and smashed to
smithereens so this is the monsters path
so far out of the Ice Mountain over to
the sea back over to snobby shores
through Pleasant Park so he has to be
going to loot Lake right we'll see next
week
week six and yes indeed the monster has
gone all the way to loot Lake and
destroyed an entire building there with
its big-ass footprint as evidence is
that right is the monster invisible or
are these updates supposed to be while
we are asleep I always get confused by
that what's interesting here is that the
electrical cabling running from loot
lake all the way to New York tilted has
been damaged
so may be tilted will have a power cut
in future weeks other areas of the map
show the summer update with beaches
filled with snow cone trucks barbecues
campfires sun beds all that goings but
the best thing of all over scythe beach
balls
everyone gets happier with a little bit
of sunshine I don't know about you but
I'm a son of a beach I said beat YouTube
don't demonetized me let's go back to
the hut to see what's going on oh wow it
has three stories I want my clock tower
come on clock tower I have faith in you
let's check up on this next week and the
last update in week six let's go back
over to rock the Dwayne Johnson and his
family they continue to plant seeds on
their plot of land
one day this shall grow into a mighty
Beanstalk
but where the heck is the kid has he
found that dog yet
oho check this out he does crazy parkour
acrobatics now this boy is becoming a
man and the dog we saw last time
urinating on a tree he's now humping a
tree
come on epic what are you doing hang on
what's the dog gonna do when he meets
the boy later in the story I thought
this was a child-friendly video goob
oh and just as I was uploading this
thing appeared miss not be Shores it's
confirmed to be a fought by challenge
[Music]
week 7 has arrived with a few tasty
updates to the map first things first
this ducks now yeah it's legit once
again a summer update for the two weeks
of summer two weeks I'd have called it
the fortnight fortnight you suck I will
stop these terrible puns once you start
using coded amaru alright the biggest
update this week is linked to the main
storyline check out the old volcano the
power plant has transformed into this
looking at the design I reckon this is
humanity's way of fighting the polar
peak Monster
have you seen Pacific Rim a hulking
great mech takes on a freaky Godzilla
like beast time for us to witness that
in a live event in fortnight I can't
wait over to the family made of stone
it looks like the parents are enjoying a
little time away from their little brat
of a son Dwayne the rock Johnson is
straight up giving sharon stone the eyes
to come to bed eyes okay maybe not he's
just relaxing after planting his crops
his son Kid Rock is busting this pose
can't be topped my friend
live your dreams he's actually spotted
something though another plant by the
looks of it maybe he's going to pick it
up for his parents and take it back home
I said a few weeks ago that I want a
magic Beanstalk here could it happen
what do you think here's my guess the
boy falls and the dog catches him but
where the heck is the dog anyway oh
there he is she by a tree sitting
sitting by a tree sorry will their paths
ever cross let's check back next week
[Music]
it's week eight what could have
developed in the fork knife world well
let's start with what watch nothing no
difference just the same see you next
week back to the family mama has spotted
something holy balls Kid Rock is trying
to grab the flower from last week
chill out mama cuz Kid Rock is made of
strong stuff you could say he's a rock
in situations like this
he's bolder than most kids he takes
nothing for granite hey okay no more
puns
there's no fracking way I'll keep going
with these puns so will the dog save Kid
Rock he's currently sniffing around this
area by an outdoor toilet more on that
rock family next week and now for the
big one it's here we look to be right
about a huge mech coming to fort night
the first part has arrived at the power
plant two feet and half a leg this may
take longer than we thought but slowly
and surely over the coming days we will
see this built upon so keep an eye on
this area prepare the island for
annihilation by the way during the live
event I challenge you to land on top of
the beasts while they are fighting can
you do it send me a screenshot if you
can please and finally the next
crossover event looks to have started
over at the mega mall if you didn't know
the ice cream parlor in mega mall scoops
ahoy is in fact a place found in the
series stranger things not only has the
venue given as ice creams to munch on it
has also given us these held doors they
act like portals just like the ones in
whaling woods a few seasons back I found
six so far so have a look around and see
if you can spot any more instantly
transport from one side of the mega mall
to the other looks like exciting times
ahead and stranger things to come
so there we go only 16 days left of the
season when I'm saying this and what
will happen next
impress us by predicting it in the
comments below a huge thank you to those
who use code Anna Mario you know this
but you make these videos possible
I Love You 3000 I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade come and talk to me
over on Twitter if not I'll just see you
here next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]